E aí, galera que assiste o meu canal, tudo bom com vocês?
Comigo está tudo muito bem, hein?!
Graças a Deus
Tá ótimo
Eu estava assistindo no Youtube esses dias
No YouTube, que é o site que eu faço vídeos
E eu vi o vídeo de uma menina que fala português, ela é uma loirinha
E é legal demais, Por que? Porque ela mora onde? Na Finlândia!
Não sei, é um país que fala lá um negócio estranho
E ela fez um vídeo falando português
Porque pra eles, português é dificil pra caralho
Mas, aqui, a gente estuda inglês
Então, nós não sabe falar inglês
Mas, quando a gente estuda inglês na escola
Nós sabe um verbo to be
Nós sabe responder qual é a cor que nós gosta
"What's your favorite color?"
PINK
Chega a encher a boca
"PINK"
Então, a gente tem uma noção
Então, eu resolvi fazer um vídeo tentando falar uma língua que, a gente,  é difícil mais de falar, qual é?
JAPONÊS
Botei aqui no tradutor do Google mesmo
BOM DIA
Yoi tsuitachi
Vamos lá, um mais difícil
Eu estou com muita fome
Não, Eu não to com mar... não to com fome não
Eu quero comer
É o que, menino?
Como é carne? Como é carne?
Carne
Hummmmmm... Niku
Quer dizer que tu gosta de Niku né?
Eu quero comer carne
Não, não quero comer carne não
Me dê leite
Pra comer carne, é uma dificuldade dessa...
Eu quero comer ovo
É ovo é? Isso é que ovo?
Ovo
Como é?
Tamágo?
Ahh, por isso que quando passa dieta, é só ovo que o povo come
E aê bicho, ta bem "maguinho" hein?
Pois é, estou na dieta
Pois é, tá comendo só ovo, né?
Como é que tu sabe que eu to comendo ovo?
Por que tu ...
"Ta mágo"
Eu quero comer picolé
Bom, concluímos que no Japão eu morro de fome
O que que eu vou comer no Japão, se eu não consegui pedir um ovo?
Eu quero comer um cu
Cu
E aí, cara de Shiri?
Por favor, pode me dizer onde fica um restaurante?
Pode me dizer onde come capim?
Porque pra me dizer onde é um restaurante é todo esse negócio aqui...
Tá, isso aqui é pra comer capim...
Eu não consegui ser uma vaca no Japão
Isso aqui é pra comer capim, ó, capim...
Março, ainda é em março
Naruto
Dragon Ball Z
Yudi Tamashiro
Bom dia & Companhia
Bom dia galera do SBT, está começando mais um...
Com Priscila Alcântara e...
Que mais? Vamos dizer que eu estou no Japão e estou sem dinheiro pra pegar um táxi
Então, a gente vai pedir um táxi, né?
Oh "f@# da p@#, pode me dar dinheiro?
Não, não dá não.
Nem roubar dá, no Japão
Perdeu, playboy
Tá, eu não ia conseguir assaltar
Primeiro, que eu não sei falar Japonês
Segundo, que se eu conseguisse falar Japonês eu iria começar a rir na mesma hora
Quem diabos que respeita um assaltante sorridente?
Eu vim do Piauí
Então eu to lá né... no... no Japão, né?
Ah, Whindersson, como é que... como é que é?
Tu veio de onde?
No caso, o cara perguntou pra mim, né?
Aí eu digo
Eu vim do Piauí
Piauí, pra você que está no Japão é um estado aqui do Brasil
Onde eu nasci
Eu falei, eu falei bem certinho
É certinho, sabe por que? Porque tem aqui, dá pra, ó, quer ver ó....
Agora, eu enviando meus currículos agora
Cara, segundo grau completo
Sou fluente em português e Japonês
Colocar na bio do meu Instagram agora
Fluente em Japonês
Pow, se o cara sabe tocar um Dó, e um Ré, bota lá no Instagram "Brazilian Singer"
A desgraça véa dessa
Por que que eu não vou botar coisa de Japonês?
Whindersson sabe falar Japonês?
Se eu sei falar... O meu forte é Japonês, abestado
Fui eu que traduzi o Naruto pro SBT passar
Te liga, macho, tu não sabe das coisas fica falando
Vai tomar no c*
Não sabe das coisas fica falando...
Que diabo é isso que tu ta falando?
Tá engasgada é?
Então, eu já estou formado, né
Se você gostou desse vídeo clique em gostei aqui no YouTube
Volta lá no Facebook, isso é muito importante, tá?
Muita gente tá aqui nesse vídeo no YouTube porque veio lá do Facebook que viu a postagem
Então, você curte a postagem no Facebook
Que o Facebook vai sempre ficar te enviando os meus vídeos, tá?
E pra não perder os vídeos aqui no YouTube
É só se inscrever no canal
Marca seu amigo que tem cara de Japonês lá no Facebook
Ou que sabe falar Japonês,
Ou que quer aprender a falar Japonês
E aqui no YouTube eu quero que você comente aqui embaixo uma outra língua que você acha bem difícil de falar pra eu fazer um outro vídeo desse
Tamo Junto, um abraço pra todo o brasileiro que mora lá no Japão, ou na China ou em qualquer lugar do mundo
Obrigado por estar me assistindo, tamo junto, beijão!
Valeu!
É nós!
Pow, me mandaram uma mensagem aqui
Como é que é tomar no cu?
Valeu!